scènes de guérilla urbaine sur un
tronçon de la route panaméricaine près
de la ville de trujillo à 500 km au nord
de lima pour tenter de dégager les voies
occupées par les manifestants
une cinquantaine de policiers font usage
de grenades lacrymogènes et tirs de
grenaille
le bilan est lourd au moins deux
manifestants sont tués depuis début
décembre
les travailleurs agricoles péruvien
dresse régulièrement des barrages sur
les principales routes du pays
ils réclament de meilleures conditions
de travail et une hausse de leur salaire
480 euros par mois minimum pour un
travailleur et sa famille avec moins
deux enfants
480 euros c'est ce que nous réclamons
nous ne sommes pas des bandits et on ne
veut pas gagner plus que les cols blancs
nous voulons juste de quoi survivre et
c'est la somme dont nous avons besoin
les premières manifestations avaient
pourtant permis l'abrogation le 4
décembre dernier d'une loi agricole qui
privait les travailleurs de certains
droits et limiter leurs salaires depuis
une nouvelle version de cette loi était
en discussion loi finalement voté ce
mardi par le congrès péruvien après plus
de vingt heures de débat les
travailleurs agricoles recevront ainsi
une prime de 62 euros soit une hausse de
30% du salaire minimal actuellement fixé
à un peu plus de 205 euros
pas assez pour les agriculteurs qui ont
donc une nouvelle fois protesté après le
vote de la loi entraînant une répression
violente de la police
une police péruvienne déjà critiqué pour
avoir réprimé les manifestations lors de
la liste
bender martin biscarrat entre le 9 et le
15 novembre dernier à lima la capitale
deux manifestants avaient été tués et
plus de 200 autres avaient été blessés